einen wunderschönen guten abend hier aus
kiew bei bild live wir sind weiterhin in
der hauptstadt bild bleibt in der
hauptstadt bild berichtet über das was
hier in kiew passiert heute abend mit
zwei ganz besonderen gästen vitali
klitschko und wladimir klitschko vitali
die situation in der hauptstadt
deutschland nimmt anteil deutschland hat
sorge dass die russische armee hier die
hauptstadt einnehmen könnte wie ist die
aktuelle situation
gespannt die letzte macht die donau war
vom abend bis morgen früh das ist die
ganze stadt geschüttet und ich bin fest
überzeugt keine einzige anwohner hat
gesprochen was letztes nacht morgen früh
ein regierte hatte in einem um
eine eine haus getroffen eine hochschule
raus
auch weil viel wurde er verletzt und zum
glück ist keine gestorben draußen aber
wir sehr viele gestorbenen zivilisten
und sehr viele verletzte und
auch glaube ich 1000 gestorbenen
russischen soldaten um und das ist wie
bezogen die amateure von allen seiten
ist eingekesselt
wann gegessen und norden von
weißrussland sehr viele panzer vom
westen
noch prosieben haben wir uns vom westen
vom besten dem machen auch eine
schritt für uns
beide und ein teil von der decke vom g
vor dass dies eine
ca das ist eine runde und um unsere
stadt zu machen ich möchte eine sagen
ich möchte gedanken an alle freunde
heute eine gute nachrichten war endlich
mal deutschland hat den schäden die die
waffen an zulieferern weil die ganze
welt sieht wie ganz glückliche person
wir sind fröhliche menschen ob aber wer
muss und unsere land unserer familie
unsere kinder unsere heimat beteiligen
ich habe keine andere wahl wir sind
friedliche menschen aber sie muss um
waffen unsere hände wladimir du hast
angekündigt dass du die stadt genauso
wie vitali mit verteidigen willst wie
nimmst du in diesen stunden es geht
wieder auf eine nacht zu die situation
and irrt war und wie gefährlich ist sie
auch für euch beide
sie haben paul gestern meine frau
sie ist vor eine stunde angeschossen
wollten erschossen worden ich habe noch
keine informationen
wie sie dort wie sie noch am leben das
wir gehen es gerade gecheckt aber die
frau die mit drei kindern
protestiert hat gegen diesen
blöden krieg und sie ist jetzt für eine
stunde
erschossen worden das was macht das mit
dir was macht das mit euch und wie ist
es hier jetzt zu kämpfen um die stadt um
deine heimatstadt es geht nicht um
heimat es geht um diesen frei werte für
die man sich entschieden hat und jemand
wird uns zeigen und wie wir leben
sollten wir haben unsere wahl getroffen
das ist unser land unsere entscheidung
unsere freiheit freiheit für unsere
kinder für die zukunft auch ich glaube
es ist viel mehr im spiel als nun die
stadt aber was macht das mit euch beiden
viele in deutschland wieder wahnsinnig
viele reaktionen bekommen auf eure
beiträge
da sagen die menschen da sage ich auch
ich ihr könntet in hamburg wurden in los
angeles ihr habt box millionen gemacht
warum riskiert ihr jetzt hier leben
in dieses land
unsere welt und das hier ist unsere
wurzeln dass unsere familie das ist
unsere freude dass es wie kommen auch
keine dass es mir liegt in deutschland
werden in deutschland adoptiert weil man
kann auch sagen ich fühle mich nicht
fremd in deutschland um deutschland zu
auch nicht fremd das land für mich aber
draußen ein buch renaissance oder wand
wo wir sind aufgewachsen und mit zu
unserem land wir haben unsere zukunft
und wir mussten verteidigen unsere
zukunft in unserem land es gibt gar
keine andere es vor allen die mir du
hast auch eine zeit lang in den usa
gelebt hast du jemals in diesen tagen in
diesen wochen wo die lage immer
dramatischer wurde hier in kiew darüber
nachgedacht dass du dir verlassen
solltest um zu überleben umgekehrt ich
bin junkie com
vor kurzem auch in europa und in suhl
gekommen weil es mein bruder
meine oder unsere mutter mein freund
kreis und vor allem ihr diese krise ich
darf nichts verpassen ich muss unbedingt
dabei sein weil es geht wirklich um die
werte und vor allem um das wählen der
ukraine für diese frei
und die entscheidung zu kämpfen dafür
dass stehen das ist nicht wir wollen
dass es um werte wir wollen eine moderne
europäische staat zu sein einige träumen
dafür deswegen in europa momentan damals
gestanden weil wir wollen einen teil von
europa die europäer mit unserer
mentalität geografisch damit unsere
geschichte wie dies in therapie und
putin ist damit es nicht an schramma
will zurück zu seinem werk eine zugabe
kommt uns auch deswegen die kämpfen für
unsere werte es gibt berichte dass ihr
auf möglichen todeslisten stehen könnten
von kadir dorf von den tschetschenen
aber auch von wladimir putin was macht
das mit allem
es geht nicht um lohn uns auf der
todesliste steht es das land und die
ukraine die sind schon gestorben so
werden
aktuell
es ist wie gesagt werden sie hier gerade
mit dieser theorie unterwegs sind es ist
einiges
um die wand muss nicht sterben
russland akzeptiert nicht wie hoch eine
frage gesagt dass es immer was los und
das existenzrecht abgesprochen der
ukraine abgesprochen da stimmt deswegen
das sägen wir es geht nicht darum wohl
sparen das geht nicht und andere länder
wie es geht um viel mehr weil
hier ist unsere eltern unsere freunde
unsere mentalität und sind deswegen
müssen wir eben unsere wand sein und für
unsere waren zu kämpfen das ist ja die
menschen fragen sich in deutschland was
können sie tun um euch um die ukraine um
die menschen und zu unterstützen jetzt
müssen wir das interview ab rechner das
ist
[Musik]
okay wir müssen jetzt runter das war das
interview mit wladimir und vitali
klitschko damit gebe ich zurück real es
gibt eine bombardierung gefahr wir
müssen runter dankeschön